how many points for hitting a berry ten  points and if you hit gram it's a  hundred bonds away  not even close  is that all you got damn it hit harder  by rain that's a good one you've met the  croods they've been called prehistoric  i'm so hungry i could eat a pig  and you've met the betterments they're  more evolved we have a system to run our  farm  [Music]  don't touch it  now they're sharing one big house  [Applause]  and facing the future together  i taught sandy how to eat with a fork  actually she's using it as a weapon  this is the good stuff get ready for an  all-new animated series this song based  on the hit movie the crudes at new age  the future of fun awesome starts here  steady the line like this  [Music]  just empty your mind and think of your  happy place friendship is like a flower  it's beautiful but it needs time to grow  the croods family tree when you know  caves as well as i do they're not  dangerous at all  see  safe as it  gets  [Music]